hello and welcome to a week eight
edition of the Beacher report fantasy
football show presented by State Farm my
name is Adam Levitan of establish the
run.com as always joined by Michael
Leone of establish the run.com as we get
set for Halloween weekend a frightful
weekend if you will I hate all holidays
except for Halloween my favorite holiday
of the year Leon how's it going today
pretty good you know I got some laundry
to cheer for tonight and I that's not
your favorite thing either but uh yeah
Halloween week things are great
Halloween weekend on today's show we are
going to go over some treats guys that
we think are good starts this week some
tricks some guys we think are poor
starts this week of course we'll also
get into the bundles as we do each and
every Thursday here and we'll take some
questions from chat actually let's start
right there from spicy sponge says who
should I play this week jacobe Meyers or
Curtis Samuel I mean my first gut Leone
is that the Raiders only throw
effectively to two guys Joey Myers is
one of them meanwhile the commanders
throw the ball to a million different
guys every week my first gut here would
be jacobe what do you think jacobe or
Curtis Samuel this
weekend I'm with you on jacobe Meyers
the target share is so concentrated
there's a chance we get Jimmy G back we
get a dome game I think the Raiders are
going to have to be throwing as
underdogs as you said Washington spreads
it around a little bit more Sam H is
taking sacks left and right so even if
they drop back a ton as underdogs
against Philly things could get ugly
there so I'm on Myers
here all right let's get into it with
this week's segment this week's topic
which is players we think are starts
players we think might underperform this
weekend we will start with a
treat in Chris
olave I'm waiting for a fancy graphic
here yes there it is oh but we're
missing the candy corn in the back guys
I don't know if we're supposed to do it
now or at the end but I will say Chris
olave is in an awesome spot this week
okay Derek Carr has been Captain check
down at outrageous rates there is no
reason to check down against
Indianapolis Colts because they are
getting shredded in the secondary
particularly by perimeter wide receivers
Chris alve is such a talented player
this is I think the Derek Carr Chris
alave Breakout game for this season
really like this spot here Leon anything
to add on that one and we need to make
sure we get our candy corn so don't go
to the next one until we get our candy
corn yeah I mean the pace of this game
should be great too both uh the Saints
and the Colts are averaging nearly 70
plays per game the Colts in addition to
averaging you know 68 plays per game or
whatever are giving up almost 70 plays
per game as well so should be a ton of
play volume here a lot of pass attempts
for Carr and the Saints yeah it's it's
definitely a good spot especially when
you look at the you know Board of games
this week there's kind of some ugly team
totals and whatnot so we'll take High
Pass volume in a dome for
sure a treat Chris
olave yes there it is the Candy Corn
beautiful okay let's keep it moving here
to a
trick Jackson Smith and jiga now
interesting stuff going on with Jackson
Smith and jiga was one of the biggest
fantasy stories of last week would DK
meaf play would DK meaf sit DK meaf ends
up sitting and Jen had a nice game four
catches 63 yards and a touchdown his
usage was not that great compared to
what it was before in other words his
role didn't really change Jake Bobo
actually took most of DK mf's role and
jsn stuck in his role however he did see
the ball deeper down the field over 10
yard a DOT and I think just things are
looking up for jsn in general but now
Browns and DK meaf back if you had jsn
this week Leone what do you
think yeah I think he's a sit in most
leagues this week long term still love
jsn I think breakout second half of the
season it's going to happen but this is
a week where you know you hit on DK C
being back the Cleveland defense is
awesome and that's combined with the
fact that they're starting PJ Walker at
quarterback so that leave Seattle is
three and a half Point favorites in a
game with the total at just 38 so could
be a weird situation where we don't get
a ton of pass volume out of Seattle
because of the team's opposing team's
quarterback and then when they do pass
the efficiencies in doubt with you know
how good the Cleveland defense is so I'm
G to call jsn a trick this week
[Laughter]
this is like the Haunted Mansion in
Disney World all right we're not gonna
say this time whether it's a trick or a
treat we're just GNA talk about niji
Harris here nji Harris has been losing
work for most much of the season to
Jaylen Warren but has somewhat
solidified a role here as the 1A ahead
of Jaylen Warr difficult matchup this
week I think an underrated difficult
matchup for nji Harrison the Steelers
Run game against the Jacksonville
Jaguars who have been very good against
the run this year Leone trick or treat
on niji Harris this
week I'm gonna say it's a trick here
with nii Harris
Jacksonville you gota wait till the oh
they did
it I blew it I blew it
3.6 yards per carry they're allowing the
result has been opposing offenses are
throwing against them at a way higher
than expected rate so that's something
we've seen with Pittsburgh too where
they want to run the ball with nii and
they just can't they get in second and
long third and long they have to bring
in Jaylen Warren they have to throw the
ball I think we see a similar situation
this week there's a difference between
what they want to do and what they can
do and that leaves n left out in the
cold trick on naagi Harris
fourth one for this week is Josh DS
we're going back to that Saints Colts
game man Josh DS looks good you know and
he's playing a role where like in
fantasy I think people get caught up as
a negative on on undersized slot guys
but man when these guys hit they hit in
such a big way the slot role is so good
for fantasy and we've seen big slot you
know Aman R st Brown cidd lamb Cooper
cup these guys be some of the best
players in all of fantasy I'm not saying
that Josh DS is going to be that but he
has a really good role right now and his
splits with Gardner minu are really
really strong I saw Josh DS was
available still in a ton of leagues out
there which actually really really
surprised me Leone trick or treat on
Josh
DS yeah three of the last five weeks DS
has posted a Target share of 23% 27% 26%
so he can get up there in terms of
volume and we talked about Chris alve
talked about the amount of plays that
are going to be run um it's really huge
in this game Pat thorman who does our
snaps and Pace article over at establish
run for us has this as one of the pace
up games this week so I'm in on Josh DS
As a
treat boom candy does this sound from
Zelda you wouldn't know all right we'll
take a pause here on on the Trigg or-
treats answer some more questions from
our friends in chat always appreciate
everyone who was so nice and kind to us
in the chat Michael says should I give
up Tony Pard to get both puka neua and I
believe this is Joe Mixon so you're
giving up Tony Pard to get puka nakua
and Joe Mixon each week we do do a top
150 rest of season rankings list we
still have Tony Pard in the top 10 and I
feel good about that I know there's ton
of people out there that are worried
about Tony Pard his explosiveness the
way he's being used schedule is about to
get real real soft for Tony Pard here so
I don't like giving him up but man puka
is a pretty good asset to have right now
also Leon what do you think about this
one Pard for puka and
Nixon yeah I mean we talk a hit on this
a lot but some of it depends on your
roster construction you know if you
really need to pick up a wide receiver
starter it's going to be tough to do too
much better than this we've got puka
20th overall in the rest of the season
top 150 so you're dropping down about 10
spots from par deuka but you're getting
a viable every week replacement in Joe
Mixon who you know he's a frustrating
player I don't think the playoff
schedules that's great for Cincinnati so
that's something to keep in mind but
this seems like a pretty even trade for
me so it would really just depend on you
know the depth of your
squad I can't face Joe Mixon I'm going
the Pard side man I think Joe Mixon
might be just like Ezekiel Elliott
levels of GG from what we saw like Zeke
in Dallas last year um so yeah uh Hector
says Carr or burrow this week so
Hector's on it man this is a really good
spot for Derek Carr and a difficult spot
for Joe burrow against San Francisco but
Joe bur's coming back healthy now off
the calf and T Higgins will be fully
healthy for this game against the 49ers
Leone what do you think Derek Carr or
Joe burrow this
week uh as favorable of a spot as it is
for Carr I have to go Joe burrow uh just
has you know too much in his favor in
terms of his own individual Talent and
you know the talent of the wide
receivers around him with Higgins coming
back and Jamar Chase being Jamar Chase
so I I just I'm not gonna start Derek
Carr over Joe burrow and our our
projections this week reflect
that Kyle says do you trust Rashad white
as an rb2 this week so this is actually
something that I've been thinking about
a lot today oddly because we were
looking at some props in this back field
and uh Kean vaugh played more than I
thought that he would of late and
getting Chase Edmonds off IR tonight he
has been activated we do think that
chase Edmond is actually going to play a
somewhat meaningful role in this game I
could see Rashad white anywhere from 80%
of the running back touches to 55% of
the running back touches here tonight I
think they've grown frustrated with
Rashad white and for the record I don't
even think it's Rashad White's fault
like I I think this run game is actually
pretty broken but they are frustrated he
could see a reduction in role but I
don't think that's the likeliest case so
yeah any thoughts on Rashad white
tonight against your Buffalo Bills I
this Buffalo Bills defense my God
they've lost like eight eight good
defensive players already this
year yeah and even with that said
they're Tampa Bay nine and a half Point
dogs I think they're going to have to
throw a good bit in this game and
buffalo is one of those defenses that
wants you to throw short they want you
to take the check down we've seen that
in you know our DVP against running
backs we have the bills inflating Target
shares so I do think in full PPR leagues
I'd still roll out Rashad white as a
low-end running back too just because I
think like even last week you know
playing 76% of the snaps or so he got to
like 15 full PPR points basically doing
nothing just because the reception
volume is so huge for running backs so
full PPR I think he's an rb2 if you're
like half PPR standard League where the
efficiency the touchdown upside matters
a little bit more I'd probably gamble
elsewhere all right let's jump into the
fantasy bundles presented by State Farm
we're bundling your home in auto
insurance is just another way to save
with the personal price plan so you guys
as who are new to the show bundles are
quarterback pass catcher combos we think
are set up well this week for anyone who
plays DFS DFS is kind of our specialty
and uh stacking your quarterback with a
pass catcher is very important when
you're playing DFS tournaments we'll
start with one that maybe is going to
make people throw up in their mouth a
little bit here Leon but it is Desmond
Ritter to Drake London now call me crazy
last few weeks man Desmond Ritter's been
playing way better and they're starting
to trust him I think a little bit more
they still want to hide him massively
but hide but trust him a little bit more
this Titans team is very good against
the run and very bad against the pass
they just got rid of Kevin Bayard in
that trade to the Philadelphia Eagles
Drake London if Drake London played for
another team everybody would know about
Drake London this guy's an awesome
awesome NFL wide receiv receiver so I
think Desmond Ritter Drake London really
really sneaky one this week Leon you can
go to our next bundle
here yeah next bundle Jaylen Herz to AJ
Brown last time they played Washington
they absolutely tore them up uh we hit
on AJ Brown 40 to1 to lead the league in
receiving that week so that was exciting
it was you know back and forth game and
what we've seen is the Washington
secondary is so bad that teams will
choose to attack back at them that way
even if they are favorites like
Philadelphia is and we've seen AJ Brown
continue to separate from Devonte Smith
in terms of earning an alpha Target
share which is huge so I think this is
you know again a really good spot not to
overthink the game script and just take
you know two of the highest ceiling
players out there so even at high
salaries on DFS sites this week AJ Brown
and Jaylen Herz have the upside to pay
it off definitely I'll go with CJ strad
current favorite for offensive rookie of
the year to Nico Collins these guys are
coming out of their buy for a dream
matchup I mean you can do whatever you
want against the Carolina Panthers you
can run on them you can throw on them
however they want to play it is what
they'll be able to do tank Dell coming
back I think takes a little bit of
Target share away from niiko Collins but
Niko Collins Remains the alpha here if
you wanted to play strad with tank Dell
I think that's fine also but Nico
Collins is a very good NFL wide receiver
could certainly win in a big way and
we've seen Stroud immediately be a
productive NFL
quarterback Leon I'll give you the next
one here yeah you're giving me the
easier ones the slam dunk with Patrick
Mahomes to Rashi rice and what we see
with Mahomes and this Chief's offense is
they just throw so frequently regardless
of the script so again it's another one
not to worry about them being big
favorites against Denver they're going
to throw no matter what this Denver
defense is atrocious as far as right
price specifically we've been looking at
this role growing a bit the last several
weeks but it really spiked last week
with Justin Watson out 64% route
participation for rishy Rice that's his
highest on the Year by a good margin I
think the highest prior to that was 51%
so it was a meaningful jump and if you
look at the yards per route run for
Rishi rice he's at
2.65 all the other wide receivers for
Kansas City are awful skymore and theas
are sub one yard per route run which is
just absolutely egregious Tony's barely
over one yard per route run really
Justin Watson was the only other
receiver that had a decent number in
this metric and now he's out so um
absolutely going back to momes and
rice all right last one is one that we
need an asterisk on because surprisingly
Josh Palmer has missed the last two days
of practice but Josh Justin Herbert to
Josh Palmer is a pairing that I really
like if Josh Palmer were to be out of
this game Keenan Allen Aus Eckler
Quinton Johnston would certainly get a
boost but either way all the pass
catchers I think are set up really well
in a home game against the Bears on
Sunday Night Football Bears have not
been as easy to run against as people
think of late and I think that we could
see a really pass heavy approach here
out of the Chargers so keep an eye on
Josh Palmer's injury status if he's able
to go I think he's a good play if not
Keenan Allen and maybe perhaps a shot on
Quinton Johnston would make sense as
well all right those are your bundles
presented by State Farm couple more
chats before we get back into the
trick-or-treating Matthew says he needs
two for PPR Alexander Madison Rashad
white Daryl Henderson so I was somewhat
concerned by the way that Vikings game
ended last week which was a ton of Cam
acres to close out the game I thought it
was because Alexander Madison got banged
up but Alexander Madison was not on the
injury report at all Wednesday which
makes me kind of think that K makers is
actually creeping on this job in a
pretty big way I think we can say at
this point Ker's base is like 30% at
least of the running back work which is
concerning obviously we have concerns
about these other guys too Rashad white
and darl Henderson Leone what do you
think about picking two out of
these I mean it's definitely a tough
group to pick from you've got two guys
going the wrong way in terms of the
percentage of Team touches and Rashad
white and Alexander Madison and then
you've got Daryl Henderson who you know
wasn't in the league until a week ago
steps into a pretty valuable role role
for the Rams but you they're in a tough
spot as seven-point dogs against Dallas
so I think I'd ride out you know Madison
and white for one more week in a full
PPR League uh but it's it's definitely a
tight
group yeah I I would consider Daryl
Henderson over uh Madison
um but yeah I I think that's a super
close one Damen says would you trade Sam
lorta and Rashad white to get James Cook
so this would be a hard one to answer
without knowing what you would be
starting at tight end Damen because it's
so valuable to have Sam leapa or Travis
Kelce or Mark Andrews or T.J howison
right now because everybody else who
doesn't have one of those guys is just
praying that their tight end scores a
touchdown and salvages their week so
without knowing what else you could
start I would probably be keeping leapa
here if you had another good tight end
it's something I would maybe consider
but you should be able to I think get
more for leapor Rashad white probably
what do you think about this one
Leon um with you I would keep lorta I
don't think James Cook is going to be a
League winner his role obviously is a
lot safer than Rashad White's but if
white for example did hold off like Kean
vaugh and whatnot and kept his current
role I mean they're going to score a
similar amount of points and Sam leaport
is a real difference maker at tight end
so definitely worth the risk that white
could go to nothing over the next
several weeks I'd still rather have
leaport and then Benjamin asks start
concade this week listen uh I'm we got
to get to even on dalon concade and if
we're GNA do that we got to do it now so
really if you own concade I mean if
you're not starting him he almost
doesn't deserve to be on your roster but
I think he's a shoe in to play almost
all the snaps now with Dawson Knox
hitting IR he had his best game of the
season last week and you know hopefully
they can start getting him more involved
down the field but yeah I think in full
PPR formats especially I think he's
gonna have one of the higher floors
among tight ends the rest of the
season yeah I mean no knocks and no
Quinton Morris for uh the bills tonight
all right let's get back into some
trick-or treating here we're going door
to door let's go door to door to Darren
Waller's house Darren Waller got a nice
breakout of course that last week of
course that came against the Washington
commanders which is one of the most
favorable spots for opposing pass games
I do feel like Leone that Tyrod has
settled the team down a little bit and I
like Daniel Jones like but Tyrod has
played better than him for all but one
half that second half of the Cardinal
game where Daniel Jones was awesome he's
been terrible other than that so what's
say you on Darren Waller Leone
trick-or-treat and don't say
Trick-or-Treat until the
end well this is a pretty gross game the
Giants and the Jets uh 36 a half total
is really low the Jets have a strong
defense and it looks like there's going
to be some weather I know your favorite
thing Adam some some rain in this game
and I know when you just put all the
elements together I I think the floor is
riskier here than the reward is you know
beneficial for you on on Darren Waller
so for me he is a
trick trick
yes and to be clear if you have Darren
Waller on your season long team like you
probably have to start him we just think
he's going to underperform this week
relative to expectation but you probably
don't have a better option than Darren
Waller anyways let's go to Devon Smith
people are had enough of dvon Smith man
I'm getting people they want to drop
Devonte Smith they're frustrated they
used a second or third round pick on
Devonte Smith and they're tilting their
face off right now Target share is I
mean they have complaints because the
target sh that we saw last year was
almost dead even between AJ Brown and
Devonte Smith AJ Brown has gone
full-blown Alpha on Devonte Smith this
year and created a 10% Gap in Target
share between himself and Devon Smith so
what say you this week Le only on
Devonte
Smith again I think the way Philly's
going to attack Washington is through
the air the Washington defense has been
really beatable through the air we've
seen big games from you know bad teams
against them we've seen Atlanta kind of
put up huge passing numbers against them
we saw Chicago do it they're averaging
7.4 yards per attempt against that's
29th in the NFL so I do think you know
while AJ Brown is the alpha I don't
think the target share Gap that's right
now 31% to 21% is going to be that wide
rest of season I think it's going to
shrink to more like you know 27 to 23%
and that's going to leave plenty of huge
games for devont he is a
treat I love candy corn uh seventh gross
door we're going to here is
Isaiah
Pacho um it's weird because you would
think that like the feature back for the
Chiefs is just an automatic slam dunk
every week and maybe it is but they're
they pass so much and they pass so much
in the red zone and they do so many
weird things at the goal line that it's
not always as simple as it seems Chiefs
this week coming off of that offensive
breakout get another really good spot
this time against the Broncos Leon what
say you on Isaiah
Peko yeah and he's not really running
than he was at the beginning of the
season but it does seem like they're
more conscious of scheming a few things
to him we saw it last week when he took
a screen pass for a touchdown he's had
10 targets and 10 catches the last two
weeks that gives him a little bit more
floor and it's the perfect game for him
to get more touches anyways um yes
Kansas City as I said they're going to
throw a ton no matter what the matchup
is but there should still be more run
plays than usual available to them
against this Denver defense that's
allowing huge chunk plays so it's a
great great spot for Isaiah Peko he is
another
treat final door to knock on is the door
of my Sanders and you know you guys
aren't going to believe this but when
you go from Philadelphia to Carolina
things start to get a lot harder uh for
you and in every sense it's gotten a lot
harder for my sanders he's now part of
this 0 and six Panthers team and during
the by week Frank Reich their head coach
came out and was like well we don't even
really have a starting running back
anymore and Frank Reich gets it because
chuba hubard is outplayed MIL Sanders
for the entire year based on almost any
metric
so pretty clear I think the way we're
going here my sanders Leone it's bad
right now if you have my sanders I'm not
even sure what you can do Beyond just
like pre that he somehow plays well
enough to gain a 60% 70% share in this
back field otherwise he's in big trouble
yeah and it's G to take that much I mean
when you're playing on a team that just
can't run the ball efficiently because
it's not a very good team they can't run
the ball at high frequency because
they're generally playing from behind
it's not great you know we had some good
signs for my sanders at the beginning of
the year but you know since he had that
injury and hubard started playing well
it just is kind of stacked against him
right now he is a
trick all right that is going to do it
we had Chris alve treat Jackson SMI and
jiga trick nji Harris trick Josh DS
treat Darren Waller trick Devonte Smith
treat Isaiah Pacho treat my sanders
trick happy Halloween to everyone out
there we got about five more minutes
here we will do as many chat questions
as we can because we love you all Owen
says Rashid rice or Deontay Johnson this
week leaning towards rice Listen Justin
Watson's gonna be back which I do think
matters or at least it looks like he'll
be back I shouldn't say that for sure
we'll see if Justin Watson is back I
think that matters to Rashid rice but I
also think the cat is kind of out of the
bag that rasid rice is is their best
wide receiver option right now meanwhile
Deontay Johnson coming off of his first
game popped up on the injury report
today and Mis practice with a hamstring
injury so if they're both completely
healthy I think it's really close with
Deontay Johnson's injury it's probably
Rashi rice here any thoughts on that one
Leon I think it's close enough that I'll
take the healthier player on the offense
too that just has a bit more overall
upside Jesse asks does Jordan Addison
deserve a flex start in a PPR leag this
week or was last week a bit of a fluke I
mean whenever you have a huge game like
that you're not going to see a complete
repeat but as long as Jefferson's out
and even when Jefferson's back Jordan
Addison has just carved out a really
strong role beginning of the year we saw
him make some big splash plays on not
full-time playing time and he's been so
much better than KJ Osborne in every
facet this is also a team that has
pretty good quarterback play they're
going to throw aggressively we saw this
last week another team that that maybe
they want to run a little bit more but
they just can't they're going to have to
throw so I think he's a flex play week
in and week out right now agreed uh
Chris says trade Addison Ritter to
receive burrow and Gabe Davis what's
your assessment of
burrow rest of season burrow starts slow
like this every year and he had the calf
injury on top of it and T Higgins was
hurt I'm still pretty optimistic on Joe
burrow Gabe Davis stuff looks bad I'll
let Leone talk about Gabe Davis though
as the bills resident laundry bro but
Gabe Davis stuff looks real bad right
now and that's coming from someone who
really liked Gabe Davis before this
season I mean the dude just can't earn
targets like he's out there running
every single route and can't get targets
I wonder if we see the Bill's philosophy
change a little bit I know tonight they
only have one tight end active you know
with Dawson Knox hurt but I do think I'd
take the buron gab Davis side of things
I don't know it's tough but I just think
that's a really big Edge at quarterback
and that edge is like more more likely
to be realized because there's less
volatility at quarterback than wide
receiver but it's a tough one because I
love Addison too usually I go skill
player side but I think the gap between
burrow and Ritter is just so big that
I'm leaning towards burrow and Gabe
here uh Gareth says should I trade am
man Ross St Brown for Bree Hall and Nico
Collins man those are two pretty strong
assets right now Bree Hall and Nico
Collins what you get from Aman Ross St
Brown is just like every single week a
candidate to catch 10 passes legit 10
passes if you're in full PPR am manra is
such an awesome asset but gosh this one
would be tempting for me Leone what do
you think about Aman ra for Bree and
Nico it's really tempting I mean Bree is
such a stud I really think he could be a
League winner down the stretch I also
think running back is a bit grosser than
wide receiver where you know that
differential might matter a little bit
more for Bree so I think I would make
this trade unless I was just absolutely
loaded um Nico to has just been really
awesome consistent and I mean in theory
young wide receiver rookie quarterback
it could get even better over the second
half of the season I still have Zack
Wilson concerns but he's certainly
looked better in a couple of those games
that we saw him recently and also at
some point you know they could make do
something a quarterback before the trade
deadline it seems unlikely at this point
but it's it's at least possible
all right last chat here for today comes
from chai bull bear cub says Odell
Beckham Elijah Moore and niji Harris
need to sit one and start two who are we
sitting out of this Trio here it's
pretty hard for me to start Odell I know
he had a good game last week but my God
this guy he's competing with very good
players for targets and he is no longer
a very good NFL player so it probably
sit Odell for me Leon what do you think
about sitting one out of Odell Elijah
Moore and Naji Harris yeah it's sit
Odell for me as well I just think you
know the volume the opportunity share
isn't there even though Baltimore has a
really nice team total you know do have
some concerns over n and Pittsburgh but
there's just so many more guaranteed
Touches for nii over Odell that um it's
the boring route but I think it's the
right route to
take all right that is going to do it
for the week eight Bleacher Report F
football show presented by State Farm
everybody enjoy your Halloween out there
but be safe I've seen some people do
wild stuff out there on Halloween you
know Leone is gonna be out there tonight
jumping off jumping off of tables uh to
celebrate Bill's touchdowns I don't need
you guys out there also getting all wild
on Halloween everyone take it easy out
there
four
Le oh four everybody behind the scenes
of Bleacher Report for all our friends
at State
Farm for everybody on Twitter who's I
hopefully I assume is following us at
Adam L10 two hats1 mik I am Adam good
luck in week eight
everybody